this story is really exciting for me
because it has to do with design
and your environment and i heard this
saying once
and it changed my life forever your head
is as messy as your room is
never forgot that so a local paper and
you know we love our locals in the
putnam examiner it says that
incorporating the color
pink into your living space can help
fight the winter blues
apparently pink puts us in a good mood
and make kiss all feel calm actually if
you go to our pinterest page
check out my personal board calm rooms
you'll see
where my head is at they also say that
red can make us feel
energized and that green
supposedly triggers optimism
and yellow our signature color here
leads to happiness and spontaneity you
can actually
see a kitchen um that i worked on um
because i like to design rooms and
there was this like kind of pukey green
like
kitchen and i flipped the lights on and
turned the whole thing pink check it out
yeah i did that that's on our pinterest
page too
all right next up here's a couple whose
viral instagram account was featured in
harper's bazaar
they're also featured in people magazine
and they have an extraordinary
layout in the new york times the reason
i love this couple
is because they own a laundromat
together
and they've been together for like 60
how long eric 61 years and they find the
clothes
that have been left behind and then they
reuse them
and do these elaborate fashion shows
where they take each other's
pictures and there are two reasons why i
love this story so much
three they're just awesome number two
i like people who express their love
of each other through fashion and kind
of twin or reinvent or recut i'm a big
vintage clothes shopper so i'm really
inspired by the style of what they're
doing
but also i'm just mesmerized by
the fact that tell me what you guys
think i
have always thought like oh i'll meet
someone and then
we'll have this connection and the next
thing you know like things are taking
off and
we're writing together i mean we're
collaborators or
we're making a movie together i have
always had a fantasy and i don't know
how it is for men and i
i i mean i raise your hand if you like
the idea of the romantic collaboration
with someone
i do and steve does and this couple
is like realizing that dream and
representing it in a really interesting
way
so yeah
[Music]